[Music]
hey what's up guys it's calling for the
score eSports and who said flicks were
just four offers three weeks ago we gave
you the top ten op flicks in csgo and
this week we decided it was time to give
rifles and pistols a little love as well
so whether it's a one atak flick or a
p2000 reaction shot that could be
described as inhuman there's more to
flicks than just the sniper rifle so sit
back hit that sub button and get ready
for the top ten rifle and pistol flicks
and csgo kicking off our list is kenny s
on cobblestone who in a 1v3 landed this
disgusting beagle flick onto MSL before
ending the game with an otherworldly
flick onto Schneider from one prodigy to
another our number 9 place he's coldzera
terrorized tyloo pin between four
players hold more than holds his own as
he takes down Dede before turning on bin
Tet with a filthy flick and the weapons
bomb plants gonna go down call zero is
gonna pay can make his position now
known oh oh my goodness hours articles
from called tear offs forest comes in at
number eight on our list with ap-250
flick that's so fast you'll need to see
it a few times before it even registered
no seriously we needed to slow this down
and just to see it forest he's stuck and
Fryeburg tries to stick that bomb plant
but it's a side bet to me complete and
utter destruction here in the portal is
amazing look at this nonsense
look we get a
time for some rated videos here I'm
definitely ready Wow
at number seven we've got get right with
an unbelievable kill to open up the
round up 39 against SK gaming the ni P
legend landed an unbelievable upwards
flick on to fer that instantly ended his
life a single round after that yeah
right Oh what is that reaction yeah
right
oh this was disgusting he just spots
like that he just spots the pixel out of
the corner of his eye or corner of his
screen what a snap coming in at number 6
is yet another play from Forrest who at
IEM Oakland 2017 surgically deleted
Taric with this gross deagle flick
through the wall with just a sliver of
vision so I shot from Forrest at least
to pick up one kill oh it's like better
than a pie didn't even feel like he was
behind a surface right yeah Forrest
obviously better than aimbot coming in
at number 5 is automatic at Northern
arena Toronto the newest member of a
revamped cloud 9 squad automatic was
looking to make a statement with his new
team and boy did he do just that as he
conjured up this nasty flick on dissing
Affleck but look another sight it Baba
is still here I mean it's still
technically the weaker site to go to
though at number four we've got none
other than scream the edge shot machine
who secured an unfathomable kill that
saw him run through mid doors to delete
FNX in midair with an absolutely
disgusting list the CT side is there
better side it's there cheese side where
they really struggle
if this ring what is that at the number
3 spot is Team Liquid hiko who in a1 b3
pulls off this simply back worthy kill
as he instantly flicks onto akka swith
just one bullet through the smoke
lurking in the shadows what am i we have
seen exactly I swear that's just what
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
a dren who puts on an absolute clinic by
killing two Wizards players before
ending the game in style with an
unbelievable 180 flick that left the
casters gasping for air all right
coming in at the coveted number one spot
is a flick seen across the world a flick
that needs no explanation its hiko's in
human reactions undusted too late
Garen is gonna be waiting he co charges
in dust in check reactions not even
worth an aim buck could you have got
that kill and that is gonna be a kill
that will go down in history well guys
that's our list and if any of your
favorite rifle or pistol flicks did not
make it on flick us a comment and I'll
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button